this is Star Talk
yeah I've got a question sorry yeah do
you guys really drink Tang
we drink what we call orange flavored
drink because the the name you mentioned
no bread is a brand right exactly so
everything we have like um let's let's
take a chance Q-tip okay is not a Q-tip
It's a cotton swab assembly and oh it's
an interesting and we're really good I
was in a CSA it's a it's a cotton swab
it's a CSA but we it but we want to make
sure we know what it is because CSA
could also be Canadian space agency
you know you know what it really gets
confusing though what is when you need
to take like any kind of medicine or
because it's all got it doesn't have the
brand names oh so you don't know but you
know what that first stuff is Brands
into space and just not say them like if
you ever had a candy go ahead that's
about I don't even that's right well we
have certain candy bars that you that
are we have certain candy it's very very
popular because they're small and you
can float them yeah and we call them
candy candy covered chocolates you don't
call them ww's and just like oh no oh
let's get back to this guy's question
everything has its a generic name yeah
so what do we have a generic name for
that product which is orange flavor
drink
foreign